[Music]
more taco
for Cody and moody
[Music]
since the beginning of the year the
roading works and the regeneration
errors has been going to hit full steam
and the construction of the new capo
East Road length is well underway it's
basically a replacement of cats tree and
filled with Drive and it cuts across the
regeneration area from the vicinity of
the Jones Cass intersection they've been
setting up site over the last week or so
but there is now a digger actually
stripping out the for the new road so
that job will be going through in the
middle of June following the discovery
and treatment of asbestos under the road
surface progress across the river and
choirboys South is also good this is the
reconstruction of Courtney Drive it's
the last project we've done in the area
here and we've already been through and
fixed the the sewers and the scheme
involves or we're narrowing the
carriageway and also putting in a few
sort features are hopefully twelve
vehicle speeds as we come through making
good progress and we hope to be finished
in five pile minute early to mid May
[Music]
in this update we'll be talking about
the regeneration areas in Cairo a key
and the Pines beach most of this land
will be divested to the tech kohaku
or to our Tara trust they're currently
consulting with the community on their
plans for the Syrian yes weird trust
Canada quite a privilege to actually
have been given these regeneration areas
to bring into the park so they're going
to come in too tight are a coastal Park
it's a 50/50 trust between my Tahu and
the whymark District Council and the
good bit about that is that it belongs
to the people of New Zealand so we want
to make sure that in enhancing what is
already here that we're also improving
returning and doing what we can to make
people want to use something here and we
look at this as being the jewel in the
crown of why McCreary district and we're
aiming to bring a lot more vitality back
to the area and to encourage more people
to be here
because the park stretches from the
Waimakariri river to the hoodie Ashley
mentioned in an entrance so we're
proposing you know one of the things
we're that an identified infants may be
an educational facility in the same area
so we've developed relationships with
various schools and the University of
Canterbury so we've got plans for a
community garden and a room or our
garden so one wores
natural medicines using native species
over here we've got part of the park
itself the southern mode boundary of the
park
we've got pine trees that have been
planted to stabilise the Jews but
they're coming up for the air on their
rotation for harvest and so the
replanting will be an element of fine
forestry placed in there to continue
that journey protection but there's also
the opportunity for us to plant some
native species
perhaps the wide interest provide tech
backs for walking trails and also for
carbon sequestration incorrectly the
regeneration areas are interspersed with
privately owned properties trusts have
some ideas on how this name can be used
environmentally friendly self-contained
off grid style accommodation no good
tiny home movement so stuff that sits
lightly on the landscape native
plantings throughout the area once again
biodiversity attracts more birds makes
it a much nicer more enjoyable
environment for the people who already
live here for the people who utilize the
campgrounds other people who just
utilized either the river or the park
itself the plan is open for consultation
until the 14th of April the full details
of the proposal are available on the
trust website we don't have a plan that
we're just going to foist on to the
community say this is what we're going
to do and this is what you're gonna get
you've got an opportunity to actually
say what you want to see logon have a
look see what robear provide some
feedback there's no bad ideas someone
was just more feasible than others
[Music]
and the next video will be updating you
on progress in the pipe or marine post
[Music]
for more information about the
regeneration visit any counsel service
center or Waimakariri govt tnz ford
slash regeneration